a school board in minnesota voted
earlier this month to provide extra paid
and non-white teachers if they agreed to
mentor other non-white teachers
according to documents
this design designed as a retention
strategy for teachers of color in
teachers who are american indian and to
reduce isolation and increase collegial
support opportunities
when you're one of a majority it can be
very isolating and lonely
to to have a support system in place for
them is not to segregate them it is
absolutely to support them
joining me now is cynthia garrett
education activist and host of the
session tv series and podcast so cynthia
isn't this un-american and racist in its
policy
it's completely racist sean and i love
the language of racism we want to
support them we want to make them feel
good if they don't feel it's so
it's it's such it's such liberal policy
disguised as we care about you feel good
bs and it's an attempt to return to
something dangerous and i got to tell
you makes me think about uh ruby bridges
you know because it's not
november was the anniversary of uh
november 14th i believe it was 1960 when
a little tiny little six-year-old black
child
became the first child to integrate a
school in the south in new orleans and
you know she went to school with four
federal marshals she had people throwing
stuff at her and screaming at
her and bringing coffins to school with
black baby dolls and only one teacher
would teach her mrs barbara henry now
they were in a classroom alone sean and
i'm sure mrs henry felt unsupported and
isolated just like ruby did but you know
what they did they sucked it up and they
put on their big girl pants and they
found support in each other because
that's what integration is about it's
about understanding that
support comes in all ages races shapes
and sizes i don't need only black people
to support me yes you can find something
in common with people that look like you
but that's not what we're really here
for what about the big melting pot of
america this is a country that is built
on a shared experience and ruby bridges
her foundation is so beautiful because
the whole point of her foundation is to
actually celebrate the sharing of our
differences and to attack racism through
integration not through segregation this
little six-year-old child had
more strength than these grown-ups today
yes
absolutely but cynthia you know
democrats they have a long history of of
supporting slavery and then segregation
is this just
another chapter out of their book um
where they support racism again in
whether it was 150 years ago or now
today with policies like this
it's completely another chapter out of
the same playbook and i'd honestly i
don't know why blacks are not up in arms
in general and native americans and
anybody else of color because this same
language that these people are using
this school board meeting
will be used in exactly the same way as
it slides down this slippery slope to
well these children don't feel good and
they need to be around other kids of the
same color let's go back to segregation
because it's about them feeling
supported what is this
really what
ruby bridges says it best quote racism
is a grown-up disease and we got to stop
using our kids to spread it
cynthia the uh this is this you're so
spot on i mean segregation division
never works let's talk about what's what
brings us together what unifies us but
listen thank you for joining me tonight
i appreciate it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else